[Music]
Thomas Alva Edison my boys and I caught
in a jar but before now is only flashed
across the night sky the future is here
oh I'm George Westinghouse Nikola that's
like I will be the greatest providing
electrical power in the world better
than Edison there's a contest between
you this is a battle for the brightest
minds of America today the impossible
becomes possible and the man that
controls that current controls the
future I hope you brought your
checkbooks you want to be remembered
it's simple shoot a president but if you
prefer to have what I call a legacy you
leave the world a better place than you
found it you are building miracles out
of thin air I'm working on something so
new that the world would never be the
same if mr. Edison succeeds he will send
us back so far we may never recover
sometimes we have to work outside of the
rules to get was right
that is how you truly win it maybe you
got bulges in every venture but did I
mention his systems lethal his current
kills people he's playing dirty you can
too
you can't see the real force that moves
things and it's not ac/dc it's up
towards its currency this is costing a
ports Westinghouse star my motor that is
our future you buy it
they're never gonna be anything named
Tesla ever again our futures not gonna
be paid with bricks fully copper I had
the better system Westinghouse Electric
shall endure the City of Light I built
it already in my imagination and it is
perfectly there is possibility you'll be
putting in jeopardy the lives of 28
million people tonight things could
change make up her right
Oh one man would rise
so what you trade invent or fix problems
radius
[Music]
you